avec ta van mat effectivement j'ai
réussi à obtenir de moyenne en maths
moi j'arrive en musique non mais enfin
on mate
donc tu veux devenir expert-comptable
aujourd'hui tout se complique pour toi
et ta famille puisque on novembre
dernier ta maman a déposé une demande de
titre de séjour qu'elle se voit refuser
elle reçoit ce qu'on appelle une
occulter s est une obligation de quitter
le territoire français
comment tu as vécu cette annonce alors
quand j'ai appris ça c'était le
désespoir pour moi et mes parents on a
été vraiment très triste et envoyer tous
ces années d'efforts et toutes ces
années travail ou où j'espère et je
voyais déjà 1 à venir vers moi j'ai
construit une nouvelle vie et j'ai
oublié l'ancien de sueur est vraiment
j'ai essayé de m'intégrer au maximum
j'ai fait beaucoup d'amis qui m'ont
soutenu et d'ailleurs je le remercie et
franchement j'ai vu tous ces années
tombé à l'eau mais quand mes amis se
sont mobilisés pour moi ça m'a redonné
sourire ça m'a fait chaud c'est quoi
tous tes amis d'ulysse et en première s
oui c'est ça ces premiers renoncer en
maintenant il ya les spécialités que je
suis en première générale j'ai pris
spécialité maths sos et littérature
anglaise j'adore moi aussi je suis un
fou de littérature on se rejoint mon
chéri tu vas et aujourd'hui tu vis avec
la peur d'être expulsé à tout moment
effectivement c'est ce qui se dit il à
quelqu'un on est la situation
actuellement la situation est
actuellement c'est que je peux me faire
rattraper tout moment et est renvoyé et
vraiment je
je vieillis pas serainement jeu même
quand je suis chez moi je suis pas
tranquille
enfin ça ça me stresse je vis avec la
peur est vraiment c'est extrêmement
difficile à vivre quand on est con
n'entendez pas qui monte des escaliers
cesser les voisins mais non pense que
c'est la police du coup ça nous coupe la
respiration pas peur et vraiment c'est
si c'est très dur à vivre c'est vraiment
quelle est la raison pour laquelle votre
dossier a été refusé
il a refusé parce qu'il ya eu un refus
d'un autre dossier en fait c'est ça qui
nous empêche notre demande d'arrêter
même pas enregistrées elle a été
considérée comme dînatoire alors que mes
éléments de scolarité ça apporte un
élément nouveau et je rempli les
conditions pour enfin je remplis les ça
fait cinq ans que je suis ici ça fait
pratiquement cinq ans aussi je que je
suis à l'école donc je jeu remplit bien
les conditions l'époque et ce qui
pourrait se passer et ce qui serait un
drame c'est que les parents c'est
reparti et toi tu puisse rester c'est ça
oui c'est ça ce serait vraiment vraiment
très très très dur pour moi parce que ma
force ma force de base quand je suis
arrivé ici quand j'étais dans les pires
moments
tout ça c'était mes parents en fait
nature et ils ont fait pas que ces
sacrifices pour moi je veux qu'ils
soient récompensés en restant ici parce
qu'ils aiment la france
et j'aime aussi la france et il
travaille t par an non ils n'ont pas
droit du coup ils ont même pas le droit
de prendre un logement qui comme les
autres
du coup on doit faire en deux ans dans
des studios alors ivre il ya le préfet
de ta raison fabien sudry qui s'est
exprimé sur la situation la semaine
dernière khady sy double responsabilité
ma première responsabilité de faire
respecter les lois du pays mon rôle est
de les faire appliquer sinon il n'y a
plus de liberté possible mais en même
temps je ne suis pas insensible aux
enjeux d'humanité il ya donc cette
recherche de compromis
je n'ai pas encore pris de décision donc
fabien sudry préfet de la côte d'or
c'était le 13 janvier 2021 est ce qui
vous a contacté personnellement le
préfet n'ont toujours pas d'accord
qu'est ce que tu voudrais dire
aujourd'hui aux téléspectateurs et aux
gens qui nous regardent peut-être aux
gens du gouvernement au préfet peut être
si l'on garde qu'est ce que tu aimerais
de lui dire d'abord j'aimerais remercier
toutes les personnes qui m'ont aidé et
qui se sont battus pour moi et
qu'il y en a beaucoup qui vont continuer
à se battre pour moi jusqu'à que
j'obtiens ce que je suis venu pour et
que je reste avec eux et que même après
avoir fini mes études je renvoie la
pareille à la france en trouvant un
travail ici et là c'est avec mes parents
et faire un bon futur ici et franchement
je demande la tension la tension sincère
sur mon dossier au préfet